a standoff over humanitarian aid deepens
as Venezuela's political crisis plays
out on the country's border a convoy
with desperately needed aid remains
stuck at the Colombian border city of
kakuta now Venezuela's government's led
by Nicolas Maduro has ordered the army
not to allow this aid in the aid has
been organized by the United States and
Venezuela's opposition who want to see
Maduro removed from power
now Venezuela's military has to choose
whether to obey government orders or let
the aid pass we have this report
Venezuelan soldiers keep watch at the
barricades on the 10 Dita's bridge
border crossing president Nicolas Maduro
has called aid supplies offered by the
United States a form of foreign
intervention he's ordered the soldiers
to turn the assistance away but the
soldiers have also been given another
order by Juan Guido the opposition
leader who last month declared himself
that as well as interim president I give
a direct order to the armed forces
necessary humanitarian aid to enter to
take care of your family that has put
the focus on the military personnel at
the border and their commanders which
president will they obey pedestrian
bridges of the border remain open
Venezuelans can still cross to buy goods
they can't get at home but many who have
no money to go shopping in neighboring
Colombia don't understand why the aid
shipments are being stopped I am asking
you to please open the border let the
food pass
if like you say you really love
Venezuela if you really feel something
inside of you
if you love your family your children
and you sure do love them then you need
to love us Venezuelans as well I'm
asking you please open the border mr.
Maduro Maduro has dismissed the US aid
offer as a political show in the capital
Caracas supporters signed a petition
that's to be sent to Washington telling
Donald Trump to keep his hands off of
Venezuela we want to safeguard our
rights and interests because external
forces are attempting to seize our
national wealth at a military rally on
Wednesday Maduro called on troops to
show patriotism and unite against the US
by the US Empire by the President of the
United States of America mr. Donald
Trump there is a fear this aid standoff
could escalate but for now along the
border the troops still appear to be
following the orders of Nicolas Maduro
let's cross over to the Venezuelan
capital Caracas from where dwu
correspondent Oscar Schlenker joins us
on the line so Oscar what is the
situation on the bridge right now well
the situation at the border bridge
remains blocked from the Venezuelan side
this is a bridge that was just
constructed at the border in an area
that has not much transit so it came
into focus when most of the humanitarian
aid went to Colombia was being gathered
near this passing however rushed blocked
this bridge and prevent the aid from
entering Venezuela Puerto Rico's
Secretary of State Primera marine
announced the shipment arrived evening a
passenger plane on what he said was the
secret flight so while all the attention
of the venez one public and the media
was focused on the Colombian border what
the Ricoh has
he's going a flying filled with a ton of
humanitarian aid into Venezuela in what
the Secretary of State a foot of
reckless calling a secret mission okay
so some aid indeed is getting through
but I just want to quickly return to you
know the aid that is supposed to arrive
by land because we know that the
opposition leader Guido has spoken about
that and I'd like to you to take us
through a couple scenarios here I mean
if it does end up getting through over
this bridge what happens then and does
grideau have a plan yes has indicated
there are between 250 and 300 thousand
people who need urgent medical help and
are at risk of dying people who need
medicine and an urgent care she says the
first cargo of aid sent to Colombia and
the Caribbean is enough to keep for
hospitals running for one month the food
that is being delivered it's mostly
nutritional supplements for children
which has been the most vulnerable to
malnutrition and sickness these last few
years
I mean difference we land up 12 children
who died in today from a bacterial
outbreak in the hospital in Onslow Peggy
for example so this hate is very much
needed and could help a lot of people
okay and again confirming that for us
that Puerto Rico has been able to get
aid in to the country by air as many
were waiting for that shipment by land
which is currently blocked Oscar
Schlenker with the very latest on the
situation from Caracas the Venezuelan
capital thank you
you